I remember when I was young they had
this boy in our neighborhood named
Thundercat TJ they call him TJ I don't
know what the J stood for but the T
stood for a Thundercat and they would
call him Thunder and he he was born with
some deficiencies he had hair just
growing directly out of his face you
know like one of those you know uh
almost just like the Dark Arts had just
almost like he was just one of his
parents was [__] carpet you know he
just had this kind of wolf boy sort of
Wookiee
kind of thing just growing directly out
of his face his hair and and that was
that was alarming to people and somebody
said that he was gonna die and they
somebody said it loud and I think they
said it in church and so they convinced
enough people in our area that he was
gonna die so he got to quit school and
his parents bought him a little truck
the Ford Ranger and he just drove it in
his backyard they had a small backyard
but large enough to drive a truck around
in and I remember waiting at the bus
stop near his home and and he'd just be
missing school they let him smoke
Winston cigarettes and he would be back
in his yard a little thunder just
driving this truck you know as a child
as a you know hey just a real hairy kind
of child and before that I remember the
girls at school would always brush him
and brush his hair and they kind of took
to him championed him as like a little
bit of an Oracle you know and we all did
a little bit I remember I used to sneak
over by the fence cuz his family had a
chain-link fence and I would sneak over
there and give him a sliced peaches feed
him sliced peaches through the fence you
know keep him hydrated and stuff like
that and he uh and he would just smoke
cigarettes and listen Fuji's killing me
softly he was listening to a lot he had
a couple of tracks there in the truck
and I remember
Blind Melon he listened to some Blind
Melon there and they thought he's gonna
die so and the reason why he got to not
even go to school was because so he
could die at home you know they wanted
him to have some peace and he didn't
have to you know struggle with all his
lessons and you know spelling and all of
that because you're not gonna need that
if you're dying and he he never did die
his mother at varicose veins I remember
him she died and the daddy this how they
used to make money the daddy used to do
slip and falls at Pizza Hut's and he
would sue him and he would get that
money and get that check and uh and he
died the father died doing slip and
falls he was working the circuit one
year and I think he was near like
Sarasota Florida and he died he split
his head open on a salad bar out there
you know doing his craft or his work or
whatever it was scamming you know
scamming but I remember a lot of times
when I would feel down in the dumps as a
child I would think about him and what
his life was gonna be like and what his
walk through the world was probably like
because he kept a good attitude even
though he had this affliction and even
though he as far as everybody was
concerned was destined Ferg for death
maybe heaven hopefully a child you know
you thought to think that most children
go to heaven but yeah that was uh that
was thunder or not yeah he did he last I
heard he live he was still alive what's
up guys sitting here with this marijuana
plant I think also could be just a
regular plant it could be poison ivy
brought about to smoke myself in some
itchy itchy just watch another clip
since you're already here you know I'm
saying